the fed they announced they raised rates
by 75 basis points
bitcoin goes up
what's your read
yeah i think you know just the
general perception from like a high
level is that you know as
the fed continues to raise rates uh and
as this week we've gotten you know a
second negative gdp print uh essentially
the market is kind of approaching this
as well you're getting to the point
where the fed is going to have to you
know kind of take their foot off the gas
pedal in terms of at least the pace and
aggression of
how they've been raising and they said
that in their meeting as well that
they're going to kind of slow the
interval between when they've been
raising the fed doesn't meet is again
until september so i think that kind of
sets up somewhat of a window just from
that perspective for a little better
market rally
all right now we see bitcoin's price is
reclaiming the 180 week uh kind of trend
line here what is this showing us
sure yeah so like the first two charts
are just
basic like super high time frame trend
charts so we're looking at one weekly
and one monthly the one you brought up
is the 180 week ehma so this is called
the exponential whole moving average
it's just a moving average that has more
weighing to recent price action um and
so whenever it's green as you can see
the entire chart is green that indicates
that it's in an uptrend so this is a
good kind of meme line to show you that
over the long term bitcoin can only
trends up because the moving average
only trends up
and also as you'll notice by looking at
the chart historically it's kind of
indicated kind of these macro bottoming
or accumulation areas
and this is something that we've talked
about for several months
and as we approached this we said hey
this is probably a pretty good time to
start averaging in uh and then kind of
the the sign of confirmation would be
reclaiming that line um so for bitcoin
one thing that i've noticed over the
last two years and also looking at you
know historical data as well um is that
kind of these these failed breakouts and
breakdowns have been almost a better
signal than actual breakouts and
breakdowns um in general so like an
example would be
uh the double top of last year right we
kind of deviated above the previous
all-time high from may of last year in
november of last year uh another example
would be the summer of last year uh when
we deviated below 30k before initiating
kind of that second leg up uh into the
into the back half of the year so um on
a similar note if we did reclaim this
that would essentially make all the
price action below that what's called a
deviation uh so you have kind of this um
all this activity that goes on below
that trend once it breaks back below it
basically invalidates the breakdown
initially
and so you can see the same thing
with the 200 week as well
one thing to keep in mind though and
very important to keep in mind is that
these candles haven't closed yet so
they'll close sunday at 8 00 pm uh
eastern time you know the reason i say
it's important to close if you look at
the weekly for example uh you had kind
of gotten this wick above the 200 week
but you know we ended up closing below
it at the last second price had dropped
below before uh the weekly closed last
week so uh for now it does look good but
you know just for you know kind of these
more high time frame kind of trend based
market participants maybe you want to
wait uh to see that candle close on
sunday evening to get that confirmation
that it has been reclaimed but both of
these look good so far